So, the task was, Vinay asked me, again, thanks for the kind invitation, Vinay asked me to talk, really address this question as to whether the BTK degraders really are just another BTK targeted therapy, or are we really overcoming resistant to BTK kinase inhibitors?
And I think everybody in this audience is familiar, and we've had a number of discussions in regards to BTK degraders. These are molecules that essentially lead to BTK block by mediating BTK degradation through the proteasome pathway.
They disrupt both the catalytic activity of BTK and also the scaffolding function, and that's consequently what's leading to actual cell death.
They don't require sustained target binding as a single molecule, as a single molecule can degrade multiple BTK molecules, and then there's broad mutation coverage, which we'll cover, and there's variable CNS penetration between the two compounds.
So, there's some overlap with some of the talks here, so I will concentrate specifically on the question of overcoming resistance. This is data from BGB 16673.
This is data from BGB 16673, the BTK degrader from B1. This was the Cadence 101 study, and I'll highlight here, this is a high-risk patient population as enumerated in the red blocks on the left bottom here, but on the right side, you can see this is actually a fairly heavily pre-treated patient population for the entire lines of therapy, and 90% of the patients had covalent BTK inhibitor, 20% non-covalent.
24% of the patients were double exposed, and 17% of the patients were triple exposed.
Now, on the bottom right-hand side, 90%, almost 90%, 89.1% of the patients were labeled as, yeah, were discontinued in prior BTK inhibitor due to progressive disease on the BTK inhibitor, at least a large portion of the patient population, thank God.
A large portion of the patient population.
The population actually was indeed, you could say, refractory to BTK inhibitors.
This is a very well-tolerated regimen with not a lot of significant adverse events, really some pneumonia and neutropenia, which I think one of my colleagues will cover.
Having said that, it is a very active strategy in terms of disease control, so rapid improvement in...
Platelet counts, rapid improvement in neutrophil counts, median time to response is within the first two cycles of therapy, so within two months, the patients actually have improvement.
And then I'll highlight the data here.
The overall response rate in the red box here highlighted is 94% in this heavily pre-treated patient population with rapid responses.
Most of the responses tend to be partial response or partial response with lymphocytosis.
And looking at, again, across various high-risk categories, double-exposed, 93% responses, triple-exposed, 75% responses, and even in the high-risk molecular categories, you can see substantially higher responses there.
Are the responses durable?
Indeed, that's what you can see.
At 18 months, the progression-free survival here is 65%.
So not only the response rate is higher, but the progression-free survival here is also higher.
So not only the response rates are high, again, highlighting the patient population, more than 90% of the patients were labeled as progressing on BTK inhibitors.
So at least in the question of this patient population that is perhaps resistant to prior BTK inhibitors, with a fair number of patients even having non-covalent and covalent BTK inhibitors, you can see at 18 months, durable responses here.
Okay.
And now looking across various mutation profiles, indeed, this is active, and it's agnostic of the various BTK mutations, as well as other down-bay pathway signaling.
I'm amazed, actually, the timer hasn't changed, so apparently I have a lot of time to talk.
Take your time.
Let's do it.
And presence or absence of mutations here is not making an impact on the 18-month progression-free survival here.
And so that's the difference.
Okay.
Let's move on to the next data, perhaps to address the question that was asked as to, is it just another BTK-targeted strategy, or can you overcome resistance in regards to the BTK inhibitions?
I think that's probably the strongest data set.
The other BTK degrader farthest along in development is the Neurex product, which is called Bexobrotegec.
Okay.
And so...
Here, at least the presented data and the highlighted data don't necessarily label out the patients that were labeled as perhaps refractory to BTK inhibition.
This is also an equally heavily pre-treated patient population, with 85% of the patients having received a BTK inhibitor, and 60% of the patients having been double exposed to BTK and BCL2 inhibitors.
And there are some patients that have had other sorts of therapies, including chemo.
And here, again, very safe strategy, not a lot of adverse events.
Tolerable safety profile, with neutropenia being the most prominent grade 2 event.
Very, very active here.
You can see across substantial improvement in nodal disease control.
And at the bottom there, you can see relatively agnostic of any BTK mutations.
As well as other mutations downstream of the BCL receptor signaling pathway.
And here, again, the high response is 83% overall response rate, with disease control rate of 95%.
But it's really not necessarily, I can't highlight to say this is all in a population of patients that were truly refractory to their BTK inhibitor.
So, and this is also a median duration response here was 22 months.
So, this is a little bit longer.
So, this is a little bit further along in terms of the follow-up, but certainly reflects that the responses here in patients that have been exposed to BTK inhibitors seems to be more durable.
So, indeed, they do degrade the BTK molecule, and they are tolerable, as I mentioned.
There's a rapid significant disease control, including nodal disease and improvement in cytopenias.
And I think generally I can say at least for the data that is presented for the BTK inhibitors, there's a lot of improvement in cytopenias.